[Music]
remember you once tell me a really funny
story which would you say that when you
go to a wedding sometimes in music plays
because of Footloose people surround you
who and skirt know I go to the disc
jockey and hand them $20 and say please
don't play that song
yeah because first off a wedding is
really not about me it's about the bride
and groom and it's my batteries you want
to see it of course I mean it's awful
and the bride's over there you know you
know anyway so I try to avoid that if
possible what's amazing is that I found
out you almost didn't get the role in
Footloose you almost and this is a role
that really changed your life but you
almost didn't get it no that's actually
true well well the producer of the movie
wanted me and the director of the movie
wanted me but the head of the studio at
the time literally said to them I don't
want that kid he's not there's a true
story now I was about 24 at the time and
I was pretty sure I was I mean I
[Applause]
but we did they were but they were very
they were very supportive of me these
these two guys the director in the
producer Dan Melnick and her bra two men
can been seeing a woman yeah I know
that's weird I never thought of it's
really weird
yeah that's weird but they they put
together a screen test which I recently
saw because it's on like the DVD that
they they someone literally dug it out
of the Paramount archives and put it on
the DVD extras of my screen test of me
trying to look you know whatever yeah
you've said it twice
yeah so what is it what is it what does
that real look like how do you prove
that in a short montage of clips how do
you prove that you are indeed a Fabul I
it was all about the camera work I guess
or something I don't know they put
different they put different outfits on
you know it's a lot of turning around
looking it was they put it outfit so I
mean I would come up with
[Laughter]
[Applause]
anyway she looked at the screen test and
she said okay you can you can cast a
button nice
reached the appropriate conclusion yeah
but do something about him down there
wow this is such a filthy segment um
yeah I try to elevate it you just keep
[Laughter]
my children are watching this is so many
I got to mention this so many I just
want to show one picture people make
portraits of you out of bacon hmm and
it's one of these things I wish we
portraits and sculptures there's a
portrait of human bacon and there's a
specter of you and bacon yeah looks
nothing like you now that's one you know
what's interesting about this I think
they used your hairstyle looks like it
yeah yeah right it's like my hairstyle
and then Andre the Giant it looks more
like an Easter Island val kilmer
[Laughter]
[Applause]
alright well we have a I want to say we
get to have a clip here of RIPD you've
got a great cast
oh yeah and Jeff Bridges and mary-louise
Parker it's it's it's a great it's a
great cast and it's a really funny funny
clever movie and Jeff and Ryan are the
main guys and they're they're really
great together and it's cool we have a
great we have a clip here from RIPD I
don't know this meat needs much setup i
blah well we're yeah we're Boston pot
cops and we're about to raid a kind of
like a meth lab ok yeah let's take a
look now inspiring motivating words from
detective Bobby case how about we don't
get shot today that's great advice
you're you're a good cop detective Hayes
advises we should avoid getting shot and
also everybody should put their charm
bracelets on now hey that's my
grandmother's say Christopher metal
jackass it's adorable and we're for
protection coastal protection all this
stops bullets and stops you from getting
dates
[Music]
[Applause]